today I want to talk about a fascinating
new blockchain project called crypto Inc
this video was sponsored by crypto Inc
and you can find out more about
everything they've got going on by
clicking the link right underneath this
video crypto ink is actually Japan's
first ever blockchain based video game
and in the game players collect virtual
pets called Krypton's and what I find so
cool about this is that every individual
Krypton in the game is represented by a
token in the etherium blockchain and
every token is cryptographically unique
there are trillions of different ways in
which a Krypton can manifest in terms of
physical appearance and other attributes
and each one is unique corresponding
with a non fungible token on the
etherium blockchain so each Krypton has
its own sort of digital DNA and as a
player you can use aetherium to buy
Krypton's you can breed them raise them
sell and trade them with other players
all with the goal of developing the
optimal Krypton for racing against other
players Krypton's and through raising
yours wisely and boosting its attributes
through races the more valuable that
that Krypton will become and you can
sell it for a conceivably higher price
on a peer-to-peer secondary market and
something that I really like that the
company is doing is they're actually
lowering the barriers to entry for
people who might not necessarily have a
lot of cryptocurrency experience but
they want to get involved with the game
and they're doing this by giving people
the opportunity to participate and play
the game totally off chain in order to
become acquainted with how everything
works without actually needing to get
fully immersed in anything that requires
a lot of crypto or blockchain knowledge
you can go download it right now in the
iOS or Android App Store and start
playing without any kind of technical
expertise which is not something that
can be said for a lot of these other
crypto based games and that is something
that I like about this and through their
partnership with crypto kitties which is
probably the best-known blockchain based
game in the world crypto Inc has adopted
the dapper smart wallet which is very
easy to use and it's another way in
which the game is easy for crypto
beginners to access so it's a game
that's
using blockchain in really interesting
ways integrates into the game mechanics
many of those interesting things that
they are doing but it's also offering a
lot in its potential to attract new
users and to be adopted on a large scale
rather than just being a very niche
piece of the crypto market the game uses
what are called raccoon tokens which are
used to reward players for achievements
in the game and for staying active in
the game and the tokens can be used to
redeem premium game items to give you a
competitive edge against other players
and a lot of things in the game will
only be available to players who hold
the raccoon tokens like certain events
and player statuses for example the
tokens are an integral part of the game
the acquisition and holding of the
tokens is highly incentivized by how the
game's token economy works there will be
a total supply of 500 million tokens
half of which will be up for grabs
during the token sale and looking at the
other half 30% of all tokens will be
kept in reserves 20% of all tokens will
be allocated to Goodluck three the
company that develops crypto ink and the
token system that is at play and as for
the proceeds of the token sale 60% will
be used to further develop the game 20%
to market the game 10% to legal fees and
10% to others who made the Raccoon token
system possible they did an airdrop on
July 5th the campaign will last for
about four weeks and taking a look at
the road map this september crypto ink
diary will be launched which is a closed
beta launch in october their asset
management system will launch as well as
an expansion of content and asset using
utilization so the raccoon token will
actually be used for applications other
than just crypto ink and then for 2020
the company's planning to add an
entirely new game that will use the same
token system with the hopes of adding
other new partner games we've seen a lot
of really cool games from goodluck 3 the
developers of crypto ink beating all the
way back to 2014 I'm showing some of
their titles right now on the screen
which you should definitely check out
one of which has more than 4 million
downloads
so they have a track record of game
development they're now putting into
place this raccoon token system that's
going to streamline in-game payments for
crypto Inc and their plan is put it all
together eventually create one large
raccoon token system ecosystem a broader
ecosystem that will be used across
multiple games so I'll be paying close
attention to what's going on with the
company and what happens with the
raccoon token it will be very
interesting to follow and we will have
more than likely some very exciting new
updates in the coming months about the
company and the token so look out for
those and make sure to check out crypto
Inc by using the link right underneath
this video